sergeant Irby gives a signal no and the
team moves in an officer fires a boar
thunder shot from his 12-gauge shotgun
it's a blank round but it delivers a
deafening boom and a flash of light that
momentarily stuns the inmates into
submission
put your handle sitting down send them
out all right on SRT uses the element of
surprise for the simple reason that we
need to catch them off-guard
we use their bore thunder to get their
attention everybody went to the floor
and we control the situation many
inmates think the force is excessive but
to sergeant Irby and his officers
they're a population that needs to be
controlled SRT is zero tolerance we're
not gonna put up with a bunch of talk
and a bunch of moving around we control
the situation and if we can't control
the situation then we'll shut it down we
control it you move when I tell you to
move you talk to me when I want you to
talk to me you understand what I'm
saying with the inmates stripped down
and under control
the SRT fans out to search each inmate
and each cell for any banned items
they'll hunt for tobacco drugs and the
equipment needed to smoke it we found
where they had actually had a little
glass pipes
sucking stuff like this first glances
straight c3 only mosey sometimes good to
put it up to the light
officer Spaulding has served with
sergeant Irby for a year and a half
keep your pants on I don't want to see
anything take your shirt off she knows
that keeping nearly a hundred inmates in
line is dangerous business and she takes
her responsibilities seriously you know
zero tolerance sergeant over B tells us
zero tolerance and that's exactly what
we do every corner and every object in
the cell needs to be carefully checked
even items that seem fairly innocent
like a plastic bottle can become a
dangerous weapon if it falls into the
wrong hands so sometimes what they like
to do is they take the cleaner and douse
an officer with it especially it's
bleach so anything that is not an
internal container is going to be
considered contraband inmates are
constantly finding new ways to make
weapons what the what I'll do is I'll
take that razor blade and they'll place
it in between and then they'll tighten
this up with rubber bands and we'll use
it as a shake slice somebody open with
it when that when they least expect it
one of the items found today is a bottle
of homemade alcohol or hooch which
inmates can make out of fermented fruit
bread and smuggled in sugar inmates take
anything they can that's sweet and put
it with bread and then through the
stages of fruit they ferments and then
it turns into an alcohol they make an OP
the hell out of it
but the few guys that I know that have
ever drank tit have told me it'll make
you sick if you drink too much of it
for Irby and his squad the hooch
confirms that the contraband trade is
still thriving as long as inmates
continue to deal in contraband the
potential for violence exists and that
means the SRT will need to keep the
pressure on